Voiceover:In an experiment
aimed at studying
the effect of advertising on
eating behavior in children,
a group of 500 children,
seven to 11 years old
were randomly assigned
to two different groups.
After randomization, each child was asked
to watch a cartoon in a private room,
containing a large bowl
of goldfish crackers.
The cartoon included
two commercial breaks.
The first group watched food commercials,
mostly snacks while the second group
watched non-food commercials,
games and entertainment products.
Once the child finished
watching the cartoon,
the conductors of the experiment
weighed the cracker bowls
to measure how many grams
of crackers the child ate.
They found that the
mean amount of crackers
eaten by the children who
watched food commercials
is 10 grams greater than
the mean amount of crackers
eaten by the children who
watched non-food commercials.
Let's just think about what
happens up to this point.
They took 500 children
and then they randomly assigned them
to two different groups.
You have group one over here
and you have group two.
Let's say that this right
over here is the first group.
The first group watched food commercials.
This is group number one.
They watched food commercials.
We could call this the treatment group.
We're trying to see what's the effect
of watching food commercials
and then they tell us.
The second group watched
non-food commercials,
so this is the control group.
Number two, this is non-food commercials.
This is the control right over here.
Once the child finished
watching the cartoon,
for each child they weighed
how much of the crackers they ate
and then they took the mean of it
and they found that the mean here
that the kids ate 10
grams greater on average
than this group right over here
which just looking at that
data makes you believe
that okay, well something
maybe happened over here.
That maybe the treatment from
watching the food commercials
made the students eat more
of the goldfish crackers
but the question that you
always have to ask yourself
in a situation like this.
Well, isn't there some probability
that this would have happened by chance
that even if you didn't make
them watch the commercials.
If these were just two random groups
and you didn't make either
group watch a commercial,
you made them all watch
the same commercials.
There's some chance that
the mean of one group
could be dramatically
different than the other one.
It just happened to be in this experiment
that the mean here that it looks like
the kids ate 10 grams more.
How do you figure out,
what's the probability
that this could have happened,
that the 10 grams greater
in mean amount eaten here
that that could have
just happened by chance.
Well the way you do it is
what they do right over here.
Using a simulator, they
re-randomize the results
into two new groups and
measure the difference
between the means of the new groups.
They repeated the simulation 150 times
and plotted the differences given.
The resulting difference
is as given below.
What they did is they said, okay,
they have 500 kids and each
kid, they had 500 children.
Number one, two, three,
all the way up to 500.
For each child they measured
how much was the weight of
the crackers that they ate?
Maybe child one ate two grams
and child two ate four grams
and child three ate, I
don't know, ate 12 grams
all the way to child number 500 ate,
I don't know, maybe they
didn't eat anything at all,
ate zero grams.
We already know, let's
say the first time around.
The first half was in the treatment group
when we're just ranking them like this
and then the second,
they're randomly assigned
into these groups and at the second half
was in the control group.
What they're doing now
is they're taking the same results
and they're re-randomizing it.
Now they're saying, okay,
let's maybe put this
person in group number two
and this person in group number two
and this person stays in group number two
and this person stays in group number one
and this person stays in group number one.
Now they're completely mixing up
all of the results that they had.
It's completely random
of whether the student
had watched the food commercial
or the non-food commercial
and then they're testing what's the mean
of the new number one group
and the new number two group.
They're saying well,
what is the distribution
of the differences in means.
They see when they did this way
when they're essentially
just completely randomly
taking these results and putting
them into two new buckets.
You have a bunch of cases
where you get no difference in the means.
Out of the 150 times that
they repeated the simulation
doing this little exercise here.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
I'm having trouble
counting this let's see.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine,
10, 11, 12.
It's so small, I'm aging
but it looks like there's
about, I don't know.
High teens about 20 times
when there's actually
no noticeable difference
in the means of the groups
where you just randomly
allocate the results
amongst the two groups.
When you look at this, if it was just,
if you just randomly put
people into two groups,
the probability or the situations
where you get a 10 gram difference
are actually very unlikely.
Let's see, is this the difference?
The difference between the
means of the new groups.
It's not clear whether this
is group one minus group two
or group two minus group one
but in either case the situations
where you have a 10
gram difference in mean.
It's only two out of the 150 times.
When you do it randomly,
when you just randomly put these results
into two groups,
the probability of the
means being this different,
it only happens two out of the 150 times.
There's a 150 dots here.
That is on the order of 2% or
actually it's less than 2%,
it's between one and 2%.
Let's say the situation
we're talking about.
Let's say that this is
group one minus group two
in terms of how much was eaten
and so you're looking at this
situation right over here
that that's only one out of a 150 times.
It happened less frequently
than one in a 100 times.
It happened only one in a 150 times.
If you look at that, you
say well, the probability
this was just random.
The probability of getting
the results that you got
is less than 1%.
To me and then to most statisticians,
that tells us that our
experiment was significant,
that the probability of getting
the results that you got.
The children who watched food commercials
being 10 grams greater
than the mean amount
of crackers eaten by the children
who watched non-food commercials.
If you just randomly put 500 kids
into two different buckets
based on the simulation results
it looks like there's only,
if you'd run the simulation a 150 times,
that only happened one
out of the 150 times.
It seems like this was
very, it's very unlikely
that this was purely due to chance.
If this was just a chance event,
this would only happen
roughly one in 150 times
but the fact that this
happened in your experiment,
it makes you feel pretty confident
that your experiment is significant.
In most studies, in most experiments,
the threshold that they think about
is the probability of something
statistically significant.
If the probability of
that happening by chance
is less than 5%, this is less than 1%.
I would definitely say that
the experiment is significant.